for weeks they wanted to vend their
anger over Israel's bombardment of Gaza
but they weren't allowed to German
police had banned most Palestinian
protests citing fear of anti-Semitism I
feel like in the last two weeks people
were extremely afraid they're afraid to
go out wear a c wear a Palestinian flag
it's dangerous right now in Germany a
feeling that's strengthened by this
statement against anti-Semitism
published by build Europe's best-selling
newspaper so fly directed at Muslims I
think it is dangerous because it is um
playing into the hands of the right-wing
people and it's specifically dangerous
for um people of Arab origin the
activists say Germany's guilt towards
Jews is understandable but unconditional
support for the Israeli government is
wrong whatever Germany does is never
going to free them of the guilt of of
the Holocaust so um the persecutions and
the violations against Palestinians that
are happening currently are not going to
free them of that guilt either and I
think that needs to be understood I
think it's it makes things even worse it
makes them um oppressors once again the
definition of anti-semitism in Germany
was expanded a few years ago and besides
hatred against Jews it now includes
attacks against Israel such as Express
verbally or on signs some say this vague
definition is a threat to freedom of
speech and it gives German authorities
an excuse to criminalize Pro Palestinian
rallies police in Germany stepped up
security after Molotov cocktails were
thrown at his Jewish Community Center
they say anti-semitic incidents have
increased in recent weeks they
politicized the term um
and and as a Jew I can be now defined as
anti-semitic
um uh which is something that I'm afraid
of personally you know um as as a as a
grandchild of Holocaust Survivors that
it's it's frightening he is among a 100
Jewish scientists and artists who signed
a petition calling on the government to
stop Banning protests while some rallies
are now allowed many people who support
the Palestinians feel they are being
closely watched step fast and Al jazer
Berlin make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest new news from
Al
jazer